Manuel Bojorquez is also here this
morning he has new information on the
victims and the survivors and then
welcome Wayne
good morning as we mentioned at the top
of the broadcast we are learning the
names of some of those victims at
student Jamie Guttenberg and the
assistant football coach here Aaron
Feist were both killed in the shooting
this sheriff also confirmed last night
that one of his deputies own sons was
shot and is in stable condition both the
students and staff that we've spoken
with here are expressing a combination
of fear over what happened of shock and
of being thankful to be alive I don't
know how we're alive freshmen bruna al
Aveda says she and her classmates
witnessed their teacher get shot for
like 30 minutes we were just like
praying and crying in
and then the police came and we just got
out students and teachers barricaded
themselves inside classrooms to take
cover
[Music]
sophomore Nicole Healy describes the
carnot she saw as SWAT members led them
to safety
on the way from getting evacuated you
saw the elite like two dead bodies on
the floor there were tearful reunions as
loved ones arrived on scene to make sure
their children were okay I certainly
feel for the children that lost their
lives and the parents of those children
because I'm one of these parents and
certainly not in feeling so good right
now
Broward County Sheriff Scott Israel I'm
absolutely sick to my stomach to see
children to go to school on with
backpacks and pencils lose their lives
ran as fast as I could and I made sure
all my friends are around me I just made
sure we were all safe
senior hector navarro escaped the
gunfire through a field with a group of
more than 50 students he believes one of
his friends is among the victims very
close to home it's not easy but I know
together as a family as a school and as
a whole we can get to a trauma that
clearly will forever be etched in their
minds Geoff officials here say they will
not be releasing a full list of the
victims names until all family members
can be properly notified all right man I
know you were here all day yesterday and
we'll be here today as well thank you